okay so if you're a 90s baby like me
then ghostbusters was probably something
that you saw in all aspects of your
childhood whether it was the films the
cartoon tv show or even just the weird
and wonderful toys the franchise had a
massive impact growing up i was obsessed
with it and i remember as a kid being
terrified of ego in ghostbusters too
just something about a painting of a man
looking menacing was absolutely
horrifying and it constantly made me wet
the bed sorry stay up late at night
unable to sleep unfortunately though
after the first two movies released the
franchise just seemed to fizzle out and
though i didn't really know why this was
as a kid there were a lot of things
going on behind the scenes ghostbusters
3 was pretty much stuck in development
hell for several years and though we got
a video game that was supposed to work
as a continuation of the story things
just didn't feel the same in 2014 harold
ramirez sadly passed away and when we
got the ghostbusters reboot in 2016 it
felt like that was the end in terms of a
true sequel ever been created now that
movie was pretty much completely
disconnected from the previous two films
and though it had some actors from the
original appearing cameo roles they were
completely different characters because
of that it just felt like ghostbusters
would remain as a product of its time
the original 1984 film is still a
classic but after seeing the dismal 2016
reboot i thought that was the final nail
in the coffin however there was still
some hope after death or after life of
the franchisor i don't know but
there is a pun in there somewhere now
this came when sony announced that they
were creating a sequel to the original
two movies that would follow aegon's
daughter and also her children stranger
things clearly took a lot of inspiration
from ghostbusters and when finn wolfhard
was announced it seemed like perfect
casting add to that mckenna grace who's
one of the best child actors working
right now paul rudd and carrie [ __ ] and
it did seem like they were attempting to
do something beyond just rehashing what
we'd seen before now ghostbusters
afterlife is definitely from the school
of force awakens when it comes to
basically remaking major elements of the
first film but i think the casting
choices and characters do help to
differentiate it the film clearly leans
into nostalgia and though it is a bit
memo berries at times i think that the
movie does enough things with its core
cast where it doesn't feel like you're
just re-watching the first film all over
again now because of these new casting
announcements different story settings
and of course the death of reimus it did
feel like we wouldn't get a true reunion
on screen however the movie actually
ends with the original group showing up
in order to take down gozai and save us
from the evil ghost that the entity was
about to unleash on the world it's such
a powerful scene and seeing the force
standing together on screen again brings
every emotion flooding back from your
childhood now it's something that i
never thought we'd get even when
watching the movie in the opening of the
film we see aegon fleeing from shandor
mining co and though it's a cool little
tribute on my first watch i felt like
they clearly had to hold back egon is
heavily basked in shadow obscured from
view and though it was a nice way to
start the movie i thought it was the
closest we'd get to seeing him appear in
the film throughout his ghost someone
acts as a guide to his granddaughter
phoebe but it's clear that they're just
implying he's there rather than actually
showing him now this is understandable
as well as over the last decade or so
we've had several characters return from
the dead through the use of cgi whether
it's peter cushing in rogue one carrie
fisher and rise of skywalker or even
paul walker and fast and the furious
though these have helped with the story
something about them just always felt a
bit off more times than not bringing an
actor back to life is distracting and in
the words of malcolm from jurassic park
yeah but your scientists were so
preoccupied with whether or not they
could they didn't stop to think if they
should
thus when i watched afterlife for the
first time i could understand why the
opening was the way that it was it at
least set things up for the future and
the pke meter that was dropped on the
floor would be somewhat of a passing of
the torch from the old to the new now
the film culminates much in the same way
that the events in the opening happened
gozar travels to egon's farmhouse and
the heroes attempt to trap it things
don't go to plan though and the vengeful
spirit easily overpowers the family
however at the last second ray peter and
winston arrived to save the day seeing
the three united on screen was one of
the biggest moments i think i've had in
a theater over the last couple of years
and that's not just because the pandemic
basically killed cinema had toby and
andrew not showing up a couple of months
later then i think that this would have
been the biggest moment for characters
returning this year and it's difficult
not to well up when you see them coming
back well not me
i wasn't crying you you were crying now
just hearing that bass note drop in as
the pro unpack powers up is enough to
shake your tv and it's easily one of the
best sound effects that we've ever seen
in cinema
he really felt the good guys had
returned and that they were finally
gonna put an end to gosei however goza
easily beats the trio and then all that
was left was phoebe to fight it off
standing there blasting the proton pack
at gozer it started to slowly walk
towards the young girl completely
overpowering her but you should never
give up hope and when all felt lost a
ghostly hand came in and helped phoebe
to steady her aim the music and sound
effects completely cut out and there
standing alongside his granddaughter was
aegon back in his old ghostbusters
overalls this gave the other original
members time to fire their weapons too
and the scene culminates with all four
finally standing side by side in a
reunion that we never thought we were
gonna get i don't know how they managed
to perfect the cg to this point that
reymus looks flawless but it's difficult
to even tell that this is an effect over
the years reymus sadly had health issues
and he contracted a disease that left
him unable to walk however what the
scene does is that it imagines reimus as
how the character egon would have aged
but it also brings back the actor in
somewhat his prime when we imagine the
afterlife and being reunited with those
we love we often think about them at
their best and not how we knew them
before we said goodbye having rey missed
back from the afterlife not only tied
into the title but also gave the actors
a chance to say farewell in real life
raymus and murray fell out during
groundhog day which the former directed
the pair didn't speak for more than 20
years but just before his death murray
ended up reaching out to ramus and the
pair buried the hatchet murray went to
his house and though remus was unable to
talk through most of their conversations
over several hours the pair went back
and forth recounting their happy
memories murray ended up paying tribute
to the actor at the 86 academy awards
and it's nice knowing that the two
reconciled before reimus passed away
when someone dies we often regret the
things we said and the way that we acted
with them i feel this is somewhat
reflected in the final things that the
actors say to his ghost winston says he
should have called and that he misses
him which i think is a sentiment we can
all relate to when thinking of those
that have passed on wisely the creative
team chose not to have egon speak either
and this somewhat stops the scene from
feeling like there are any elements that
could take away from the sincerity of
what's on screen in the end the
characters get to say goodbye to not
only egon but also reimus which is
something that we must all learn to do
he finally gets to build a bridge with
the daughter that he left behind and the
grandchildren he didn't get to spend
much time with callie hugs some as he
fades into the ether and we see the
other characters crying which hey if
this doesn't set you off i don't know
what will cried about five times when i
was writing this script now he vanishes
into the story night and the scene ends
with the words for harold making this
one of the best send-offs that we could
have got we close out on ecto-1 cruising
through the streets and though we get
some fun post-credits scenes i feel like
the goodbye to harold is the perfect way
to end the movie now i'd of course love
to hear your thoughts on the scene so
make sure you comment below and let me
know we're in a competition right now
and giving away three copies of an mc
box of your choice on the 30th of
january and all you have to do to be on
the chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the film we
pick the comments at random at the end
of the month and the winners of the last
one on screen right now so that's you
then message me on twitter heavyspoilers
if you want some else to watch then make
sure you check out our breakdown of
spiderman no way home which will be
linked on screen right now we talk about
the ending and how much we love it so
definitely go head over there right
after this if not then thanks for
sticking through the video i've been
paul i'll see you on the next one take
care peace